I bet Jenna when did I meet you you met
me before I even moved to LA wait what
yeah I was visiting LA and I was
visiting Esther I used to drive her to
her shows that's why in town and you
were like if you don't know esther
povitsky ski Levitsky Pavitt with a t
povitsky povitsky yeah and you you were
like the grandfather you were like the
grandfather figure you look like you're
gonna kill me all the words you chose
you said grandfather what the [ __ ] do
you mean grandfather like before I knew
you knew you you seemed like really wise
and calm yeah Bob nods right and that's
until I was like oh he's like a
grandfather
Esther he's just so wise in calm and
because you would like to give me advice
on things yeah yeah and then and I
remember so that was before I moved here
and then I saw you another time when I
was visiting and I honked my horn at you
you were driving the opposite way and I
just like yelled out my window hey and I
don't think you noticed it was me and
you really which is yeah that was me
very safe yeah yeah and then but then
you got to know me and you're like ah
not so much grandpa yeah kind of a
grumpy a grumpy character yeah like a
grumpy dirty yeah some sort of figure
the nasty you know yeah yeah and then
it's you know what I like about this
though is that if I hadn't met kalila
you would have never met kalila we
wouldn't just be we wouldn't be here I
love when you just kind of you meet
certain people which connects old people
to new people and then you create this
new thing and it comes circle yeah comes
full circle yes that's how I met Gilbert
I met Gilbert through Jenna right I
would have never known Gilbert if I have
never met kalila and then you I'd I love
that that's so true it's like a [ __ ]
spider web and we're just all dead in it
you would have never met George without
me ray or Jenna without me right right
and even Gilbert if I hadn't been
connected to Gilbert through
roommate Samantha I would have never met
Gilbert whoa how does the man you knew
Samantha before you knew Jenna Chicago
yeah and then Samantha was extra mates
with Melissa right
no Esther well Esther okay got it got it
yes and yard they're all friends Oh
Melissa Villasenor yeah Wow
so that's what I like about life yeah
you know you meet and then friends
intermingle and creates other things but
the first time I met Jenna I knew that
we were gonna be friends immediately
because the hippy thing I had driven
Esther to show she was at one of your
shows she was in the greenroom but she
was wearing just a oversized t-shirt no
pants underneath yeah yeah she had a
wedgie stuck in her butt and she didn't
bother to be discreet about picking it
she just ripped her [ __ ] right out of
there yeah I can handle wedgies cuz like
you know my OCD too yeah I'll just think
about it and she was like walking all
like wide-legged she just didn't give a
[ __ ] she was
[Music]